son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna ustedes Les agradecemos
su sintonía vamos con los titulares de
esta jornada
ya son al menos 136 los muertos tras el
paso de la tormenta Freddy por malawi
Madagascar y mozambique se trata del
ciclo más fuerte del que se tiene
registro en el hemisferio sur y ha
dejado unos 480.000 afectados
el gobierno de Australia confirmó la
compra de tres submarinos de propulsión
nuclear fabricados por Estados Unidos
con la opción de Añadir dos más en el
futuro la compra tiene lugar en el marco
de la alianza aucus junto a Estados
Unidos y Reino Unido para ser contrapeso
a China
el gobierno colombiano y una parte de
las disidencias de la antigua guerrilla
de las FARC establecerán una mesa de
diálogo así lo anunció el presidente
Gustavo Petro luego de que la fiscalía
levantara las órdenes de captura contra
19 integrantes de ese grupo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
damos inicio en malahui donde según el
departamento de desastre solo en ese
país cerca de un centenar de personas ha
muerto a causa del ciclón Freddy el
fenómeno natural ha regresado al sur de
África siguiendo un patrón en bucle
pocas veces visto por los meteorólogos
Freddy ha dejado a su paso unos 480.000
afectados y también pérdidas humanas en
mozambique y Madagascar
las calles convertidas en torrentes
vehículos sumergidos en la fuerte lluvia
en malawi el ciclón Freddy ha golpeado
de nuevo causando inundaciones y grandes
deslizamientos de Tierra según la
oficina de desastres del país cerca de
un centenar de personas murieron y
decenas más resultaron heridas o
desaparecieron también en mozambique el
ciclón arrasó toda su paso con Vientos
de 150 kilómetros por hora las
carreteras el agua y la electricidad
quedaron cortadas en algunos lugares
100.000 usuarios están sin electricidad
es caótico tendré que buscar la manera
de cubrir mi casa con planchas de zinc
para poder sobrevivir
el ciclón lleva 35 días azotando el sur
de África está por convertirse en el más
largo de la historia y quizás también en
el más impredecible se formó frente a
las costas de Australia y cruzó el
océano Índico antes de golpear
Madagascar y mozambique a finales de
febrero también allí hubo varios muertos
y miles de desplazados desde hace una
semana vuelve a afectar a estas dos
zonas
la característica los notable es que en
el mar ha recuperado el calor la humedad
y Una atmósfera favorable ha podido
recuperar su intensidad y convertirse en
un ciclón importante
según las previsiones se espera que el
ciclón se desplace hacia el mar durante
la semana y finalmente se debilite
miles de personas protestaron en
Pakistán para pedir elecciones
anticipadas y defender la labor del ex
Primer Ministro inrancan el político
presentó su campaña electoral en medio
de la movilización en la ciudad de lare
allí Cana aseguró que el actual gobierno
está presentando mociones en su contra y
en contra de otros líderes de su
formación política para intentar que no
se presenten a los comicios regionales
recordemos que can fue destituido tras
perder un voto de confianza en el
parlamento en abril del año pasado
en otras noticias el viceministro de
asuntos exteriores de Rusia Indicó que
su país dará una prórrogada al acuerdo
para la exportación de cereales a través
del mar Negro la medida es por espacio
de 60 días la mitad de lo pactado
inicialmente y permitirá la exportación
de 24 millones de toneladas de cereales
desde Ucrania
algunos lo denominan como un
pacto crudo de exportación de grano del
mar Negro está relacionado con la
seguridad alimentaria mundial ya que
permite la importación de grano y
fertilizantes tanto rusos como
ucranianos desde puertos ucranianos un
flujo que se vio afectado por la Guerra
de Ucrania y que disparó los precios de
varios alimentos a nivel mundial y justo
para evitar eso en julio se planteó y
firmó el acuerdo mediado por la ONU y
Turquía permitiendo las exportaciones
desde tres puertos ucranianos Pero hay
un problema expira el próximo sábado y
eso ha levantado voces de alarma
el mundo necesita esto el mundo necesita
el acuerdo de grano del mar Negro y lo
sabemos porque hemos visto un mundo con
el acuerdo de grano del mar Negro y
también un mundo sin el acuerdo de grano
del mar Negro
Y es que la renovación está sujeta
condiciones de la parte rusa ya que
Moscú asegura que a pesar de que los
productos rusos incluidos en el acuerdo
están exentos de sanciones siguen
sufriendo bloqueos
mientras la exportación comercial de
productos ucranianos se lleva a cabo a
un ritmo constante reportando
considerables beneficios que las
restricciones a los exportadores
agrícolas rusos siguen vigentes muchas
empresas de logística y transporte se
niegan a colaborar con los rusos algo
que podría hacer peligrar el acuerdo
global implica dos direcciones la rusa y
la ucraniana y ambas deben aplicarse
desde su firma el acuerdo ha permitido
la exportación de 23 millones de
toneladas de cereales el 55% destinado a
países en vías de desarrollo el gobierno
australiano anunció la anunció que
comprará tres submarinos de propulsión
nuclear fabricados en Estados Unidos
como parte del acuerdo aucus un pacto
alcanzado por Australia Estados Unidos y
el Reino Unido el anuncio tuvo lugar en
Washington donde Jake sallyban asesor de
seguridad Nacional de la Casa Blanca
informó que al pedido de tres subma se
podría Añadir Próximamente dos
adicionales sobre este tema comentó el
Premier australiano quien se reunió en
una base aérea en el estado de
California con el Primer Ministro de
Reino Unido aquí el presidente
estadounidense Joe biden escuchemos sus
palabras
estamos obligados sobre todo por nuestra
creencia en un mundo donde se respete la
soberanía de cada nación y se defienda
la dignidad inherente de cada individuo
donde la paz la estabilidad y la
seguridad aseguren una mayor prosperidad
y una mayor medida de Justicia para
todos y donde todos los países puedan
actuar en sus intereses soberanos libres
de coerción
este encuentro que tuvo lugar en
California particularmente importante
para el Primer Ministro australiano
Anthony alvanici dado que el premiere
está bajo presión porque este es el
proyecto de defensa en el marco del
acuerdo aucus es el más ambicioso y
costoso en la historia de su país esto
ha hecho que varios sectores políticos y
de la sociedad no lo respalden Australia
Estados Unidos y Reino Unido buscan
hacer contrapeso a la presencia de china
en la región de Asia Pacífico
aucus es el acrónimo que conjunta los
nombres de los países miembros del pacto
en 2021 Australia Estados Unidos y Reino
Unido acordaron forjar una alianza
estratégica para reforzar la integración
en temas de seguridad y defensa su
principal objetivo sería contrarrestar
la creciente influencia china en la
región
Hoy estamos dando otro paso histórico
para profundizar y formalizar la
cooperación entre nuestras tres naciones
Porque todos reconocemos el imperativo
de garantizar la paz y la estabilidad en
el Indo Pacífico a largo plazo
Australia podría recibir los primeros
submarinos de propulsión nuclear de
fabricación estadounidense a principios
de la década de 2030 estos no llevan
armas atómicas pero sí tienen capacidad
para cargar hasta 40 misiles tomahawk a
raíz de esta Alianza canberra se vio
obligada a abandonar el acuerdo firmado
con Francia en 2016 que estipulaba la
venta de submarinos franceses A la
nación oceánica durante 50 años lo que
representaba una pérdida millonaria para
el gobierno francés un hecho que pasó a
conocerse como la crisis de los
submarinos
El engaño fue intencionado había más en
juego que el suministro de submarinos
porque se trataba de un acuerdo común
sobre soberanía sellado con la
transmisión de datos altamente
clasificados la forma en la que se
manejaron fue claramente una puñalada
por la espalda
plainley
las asperezas entre Francia y los
miembros de la ucus han sido limadas
desde entonces pero las tensiones se
mantienen con china que ha expresado
rechazo a la transferencia de este tipo
de tecnología Australia en medio de las
tensiones en torno a Taiwán y las
disputas sobre la soberanía en el mar
meridional en casa el Primer Ministro
australiano albanís está bajo presión
por demostrar que este proyecto el
costoso en la historia del país en
materia de defensa llevará a la
generación de empleo vamos a Colombia
donde el presidente Gustavo Petro
anunció que dará inicio una mesa de
diálogo con el Estado Mayor central uno
de los grupos disidentes de la antigua
guerrilla de las FARC que se abstuvo de
firmar el acuerdo de paz de 2016 como
primera medida de la fiscalía suspendió
las órdenes de captura de 19 de los
integrantes de este grupo de disidentes
que ahora serán parte de los
negociadores
Colombia comenzará un segundo proceso de
paz el presidente Gustavo Petro anunció
este lunes una mesa de diálogo con el
Estado Mayor central una de las
disidencias de las antiguas FARC que es
liderada por alias Iván mordisco con
esta posibilidad que inicia en el día de
hoy
da la actitud del fiscal de aceptar los
nombres de las personas que actuaran
como voceros de esa agrupación
Prácticamente la mitad de las personas
armadas hoy
entran a un proceso de paz con el
gobierno para que este proceso pueda
llevarse a cabo la fiscalía general de
Colombia suspendió 19 órdenes de captura
por pedido del gobierno para él
esas esa organización es una
organización que tiene hiladota de un
carácter político para negociar acuerdos
de paz con el gobierno nacional en 24
Jorge mantilla investigador en asuntos
de conflicto y crimen organizado explicó
las posibles dificultades que surgir en
las conversaciones entre el gobierno y
el Estado Mayor central
el Gobierno ya ha reconocido
explícitamente al Estado Mayor central
como un grupo de carácter político los
retos tienen que ver justamente que esta
Estructura No es un grupo propiamente
unificado hay más de 25 frentes dentro
de lo que se denomina Estado Mayor
central gran parte de las dudas tienen
que ver con si hay unidad de mando si
efectivamente son un interlocutor que
tenga unos criterios claros para
negociar Además del Estado Mayor central
el estado colombiano apunta a tener
acercamientos en las próximas semanas
con la segunda marquetalia otra de las
disidencias de las FARC este 13 de marzo
se conmemoró el décimo aniversario de la
elección del Papa Francisco como máximo
líder de la Iglesia Católica los diez
años del primer papa latinoamericano han
estado marcados para acontecimientos
como la guerra en Ucrania la pandemia de
covid 19 o el conflicto israelí
palestino cuestiones donde el argentino
se ha expresado activamente haciendo
llamados al diálogo para detener el
derramamiento de sangre además por abuso
sexuales por parte de los integrantes
del clero el informe es de Max Pérez
Gallardo
10 años del humo blanco argentino el 13
de marzo de 2013 después de la
controversial dimisión de Benedicto 16
el cardenal Jorge Mario bergoglio fue
elegido como santo padre de la Iglesia
Católica Francisco nombre que eligió
vergoglio para su papado es el primer
sumo pontífice latinoamericano y jesuita
en la historia de la institución
hermanos y hermanas los dejo por ahora
pero muchas gracias por su bienvenida
por favor recen por mí
fregaste permé el Papa Francisco ha sido
uno de los jerarcas católicos que más ha
salido del Vaticano ha realizado 40
viajes a 60 países diferentes
privilegiando naciones en situaciones
complicadas Palestina Jordania cuba El
Congo y Sudán del sur han sido algunos
territorios visitados por el santo padre
su santidad nombre con el que reconocen
al papa los feligreses ha sido sumamente
vocal con su deseo de trabajar por la
transformación social del mundo
los reportes por violencia sexual contra
Menores en la iglesia católica también
han sido abordados por el argentino
desde escuelas católicas irlandesas
hasta conventos portugueses los
escándalos sexuales de la Iglesia
Católica han indignado al mundo en
Irlanda una investigación reveló que en
el lapso de 1920 a 1990 más de 9000
menores murieron en residencias
administradas por la iglesia católica el
reporte significa que 2000 de ellos
sufrieron abusos sexuales en 2021 una
serie de reportes desvelaron que más de
200.000 niños han sido Víctimas de abuso
sexual por miembros del clero francés en
Lisboa una comisión de investigación
independiente requerida por el Vaticano
señaló que al menos
4,815 menores fueron Víctimas de abuso
sexual por sacerdotes portugueses al
menos 100 de los acusados siguen libres
y en funciones
facho un sentido a pelo
algún sentido llamado a una lucha sin
cuartel contra los abusos a menores
tanto sexuales como en otros ámbitos por
parte de todas las autoridades y
personas Pues estamos ante crímenes
abominables que deben ser borrados de la
faz de la tierra
que van a cancelarte y da la facha de la
tierra a sus 86 años el Papa Francisco
se ha ganado el corazón de millones por
su activismo político y lucha por
reformar la iglesia católica
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo América aquí en France 24 a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a continuar con nosotros
que ya llega a mal benotman con toda la
información del continente africano en
África 7 días feliz noche para todos
[Música]